[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is the global
creative platform that makes it easy for
designers and clients to work together
from logos to apps and packaging to
ebooks
99designs is the go-to design resource
for any budget I've used 99designs
for many many years now I've used them
for book covers for instance mock-ups
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become a number one near Times best
seller illustrations for my multi-volume
The Tao of Seneca and other graphic
design projects and I've been really
impressed by the quality of their
designers and the designs that I've been
diffusing most recently I used 99
designs to update the illustrations and
layouts of my five morning rituals eBook
this covers my most consistent morning
routines and rituals and I offer that as
an incentive for people to sign up for
my newsletter so this is a PDF bonus
that acts as a carrot to increase the
number of email subscribers the
illustrations inside are gorgeous and I
loved working with the designer who we
selected for the project so you can
check it out take a look at that at 99
designs com forward slash Tim that's the
number 99 designs com forward slash Tim
and you can see exactly what I'm talking
about with a real world example of what
has come out of work with them nunya and
designs designer search tool connects
you directly with one designer based on
a design category or an industry
specialization style skill level
availability and more so you can really
check all the boxes that you need and
see who matches up or you can start a
contest and that means you invite the
entire community to take a shot at your
project then you pick your favorite
right now you guys my listeners that is
can receive a free $99 up
great on your first design contest so
check it out to see what it looks like
to get your first free upgrade please
visit 99designs comm forward slash tim
and click on the link in the landing
page so again check it out 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim this episode
is brought to you by peloton which I've
been using probably for about a year now
peloton is a cutting-edge indoor cycling
bike that brings live studio classes
right into your home you can also do
on-demand which is what I do we'll come
back to that so you don't have to worry
about fitting classes into a busy
schedule or making it to a studio or gym
with a hectic or unpredictable commute I
for instance have a peloton bike right
in my master bedroom at home and it's
one of the first things I do many
mornings I wake up I meditate for a bit
then I knock out a short 20 minute ride
in my undies hard to do that at the gym
take a shower and I'm in higher gear for
the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes or
whatever music hip hop rock and roll or
say low impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite like Matt
Wilbur's and I tend to do on-demand and
listen to a lot of and watch many of the
same classes over and over but I'm kind
of promiscuous and also enjoy classes
from a lot of the other instructors they
have peloton and amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and
personalities so you can find what
you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyze you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was I know work tremendously to keep me
pushing which quite honestly takes a
fair
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that's o-n-e peloton PE l oto and
calm and enter the code Tim all caps at
checkout and get $100 off of accessories
with your policy on bike purchase so get
a great workout at home anytime you want
check it out go to one peloton calm and
use the code Tim to get started hello
boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show this is a very special
episode because it represents the first
time that LeBron James has been
interviewed alongside his very below the
radar
some might say top secret athletic
trainer about details of training
recovery diet and even how much longer
he hopes to play in the NBA and I did
not have as you might expect with King
James the usual two and a half three
three and a half four hours so it is a
neat 60 minutes might come in a tad
under that and I was nervous and perhaps
even a little over-caffeinated to make
the most of the time so you have that
going for you LeBron James who is that
at King James on Instagram and Twitter
LeBron James calm is widely considered
one of the greatest athletes of his
generation and is regarded by some as
the best basketball player of all time
this interview was recorded the day
after he passed Wilt Chamberlain's
all-time scoring record LeBron's
accomplishments on the court include
four NBA Most Valuable Player Awards MVP
awards three NBA championships and three
NBA Finals MVP awards two Olympic gold
medals and an NBA scoring title he is
the all-time NBA playoff scoring leader
and has amassed 14
NBA all-star game appearances 12 all-nba
first team selections and 5
all-defensive first team honors
throughout his career James has used his
platform to inspire and empower others
through his LeBron James Family
Foundation
but you can find it LeBron James Family
Foundation org that helps at-risk
students in his hometown earn
life-changing education 'he's
culminating most recently in the opening
of his i promise school which you
combine i promise dot school he's also
involved a spring hill entertainment the
entertainment company he co-founded with
maverick carter that produces compelling
and aspirational content for a
cross-cultural audience on a variety of
platforms including digital film
television and uninterrupted in a
digital media company he incurred a
co-founded that provides athletes with a
platform to tell their stories LeBron
has a really diverse business portfolio
we won't be able to get into all right
now but includes all sorts of innovative
endorsement deals and have established
him as one of the most influential
figures in all of sports
James has appeared on Forbes list of the
world's most powerful celebrities times
annual list of the 100 most influential
people in the world and Bloomberg
Business weeks 100 most influential
people in sports and now LeBron along
with Arnold Schwarzenegger Cindy
Crawford and Olympic gold medalist
Lindsey Vonn has founded ladder a health
and wellness platform and brand that is
launching today the site we are ladder
com is a resource for reaching fitness
nutrition and health goals with tools
and scientifically supported insights
for addressing any frustrations or
roadblocks along the way ladder also
offers a community of experts for
holding you accountable and nutrition
products that are all NSF certified for
sport which is considered the gold
standard for sports testing and approved
by all major sports teams and the IOC
that is the International Olympic
Committee ladder products contain no
official ingredients no artificial
sweeteners no fillers and no proprietary
blends now allow me to introduce the
other person in this interview and then
we'll get right to it
mike Mencius Mike mencius at Mike
mencius one that's ma NC IAS on
Instagram and Twitter is LeBron James
athletic trainer and recovery specialist
a position he's held for 14 years and
Counting a veteran in the world of
training professional basketball players
his experience also includes working
with NFL MLB PGA and top NCAA athletes
throughout his tenure with LeBron
mike has quietly developed a winning
human performance blueprint that
encompasses everything from preventive
medicine strength training and Rehab
nutrition and the latest in recovery
techniques some of which we talked about
in this interview
Mike's philosophy is one that is now
commonly accepted by many athletes and
trainers as the ideal 360-degree
approach to wellness and performance it
was through this focus on nutrition
performance and recovery that Mencius
aided in developing the latter brand and
its products originally from Brownsville
Texas Mencius attended the University of
texas-pan American and graduated with a
degree in health education he's licensed
and nationally certified by the
accredited National Athletic Trainers
Association and is a 14 year member of
the National Basketball League trainers
association that is the introduction and
without further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with none
other than King James LeBron James and
Mike Mencius LeBron and Mike welcome to
the show thanks to thank you're having
this appreciate thank you but my
pleasure I am thrilled to have the two
of you on in part because it is so
difficult to do research on the two of
you together which is fascinating to me
Mike you're like the banksy of elite
trainers I see your your art that is the
product of the work that you do on
television and everywhere but you are
like Batman it's impossible to do
research on you which is is really
exciting for me as someone who's made a
job of doing that so I thought we could
jump right into questions on my mind and
questions on many minds and we'll begin
with a little bit of context and maybe
LeBron if you want to take this how did
the two of you first meet you seem to
have a very special relationship I'd
love to just get a little bit of
background and your thoughts on what
makes the relationship work so well yeah
my second year in the NBA with the Cavs
Mike was was interning with the Cavs at
the time and you know every day you kind
of I was trying to figure out a way how
I could be more consistent with my
training and be more consistent with you
know just trying to make the jump from
our rookie
my second year and you know not only
from afar but from up close I I saw the
the demeanor and the laser focus and mic
every single day on what he was doing
and I kind of resonated with that and I
just you know we started to have
conversations we started to talk more
and more every day and the relationship
started to grow every single single day
and you know I believe you know know the
rest is history at this room so you two
have done so much together spend so much
time together Mike I'd love to dig into
I suppose more than a few things but to
begin with recovery and injury
prevention I mean LeBron he had such a
momentous evening last night so
congratulations of course on that and
you're a bit of a unicorn in the sense
that you've played more than as I
understand a 50,000 minutes in your
career most hit a wall and deteriorate
after say 40,000 so you're defying all
the predictions of player decline so
Mike maybe you can give us a window into
some of that and I've in the course of
trying to do research read about say
recovery between games which I've picked
up maybe not true electro-stimulation
machines air pumped compression sleeves
soft tissue could you walk us through
some of the tools of the trade and the
approaches that you use to help with
recovery in between games yeah yeah well
I think with with the Brawn with any any
you know elite athlete I think the one
thing that we all as trainers and
therapists have to keep in mind is that
recovery never ends recovery never stops
you know if it were brown plays 40
minutes one night if he plays you know
28 minutes one night we're still going
to keep recovery as a number one focus
whether that being nutrition or a bean
hydration more flexibility exercises
stuff in the weight room it's it's it's
never-ending process really and I think
that's the approach that we must take in
order for us to be six
and provide longevity for these guys
mm-hmm and if if we look at just say the
first few hours after a particularly
intense games what what is what is some
of the triage that you pull out if your
your bag to use well we'll do like a
quick you a in in the locker room I kind
of get a quick assessment as to okay out
of the game go you know how I was this
feeling how was this feeling et cetera
and LeBron and gave me some feedback on
how we felt after each and every game
believe it or not so we'll do that
number one and then we'll start our
process of hydration and nutrition you
know cuz he's uh he does spend a lot of
energy up there so we need to make sure
that that would feed him the right the
right calories calories in like a
protein shake
etc you know a water or a sports drink
and then number one frankly just some
good food some good high-quality food so
that's that's the number one right like
right off the bat after a game it's a
it's a nutrition from there we're going
to you know like a crowd therapy either
cold tank ice bags crowd therapy chamber
you know whatever may be available at
that particular night mm-hmm and if
we're looking at general injury
prevention are there any particular and
I'll give one example I've interviewed a
number of Olympic sprint coaches and in
some cases they'll take something like
the deadlift but they'll they'll modify
it so that they're only lifting to the
knee and they'll drop so they're not
risking hamstring injuries with the
negatives are there any particular
exercises that you feel are tremendously
important for injury prevention or any
that you avoid because you think that
they could produce injuries well I think
with that question I think every athlete
is different you know based on their you
know just just based on their on your
body makeup and so we have to number one
you know before even prescribe many
exercises we have to do a quick other
body you know is do they have any
factors that are limiting the range of
motion will start you know will start
from the very bottom and that's
that's the Victo you know how much
movies do you have in your picked oh and
then you go up the chain you know the
ankle the knee of the hip the low back
in the shoulders etc once you get a
quick assessment then you can start to
you know kind of tweak your your workout
routine by adding or subtracting uh you
know different exercises the second part
of that is okay who are you dealing with
you know LeBron ceman in the league this
is he starting his sixteenth year in the
NBA he's played a lot of minutes a high
you know high quality minutes and so you
know you just have to be smart as to
your your prescription mm-hmm
and LeBron do you think that if you look
at for instance the big names that came
into the league around the same time
that you did it's it's staggering to see
how few of them are still playing and
yet here you are playing as the best in
the NBA are there any particular
approaches you've taken or things that
you attribute that to well I can't speak
on any other players or anybody came in
around my time or a little bit after me
or not too far when I came in but I know
me personally I've just been very
consistent with the process I've been
very consistent with training my body
rehabbing my body you know eating you
know you know having my body be very
clean throughout this journey because
I've always wanted to have a long you
know long career or as long as I could
be you know in in this in this in this
in this space so I've always kind of you
know some a friend of mine when I was
like 13 years old he's always tell me
you know play hard have fun and stretch
you know every game always play hard
have fun and stretch and that kind of
always kind of stuck with me till when
even I got an NBA like always stretching
and keeping my body flexible keeping my
limbs flexible so it you know I can
contribute to that and doing it
consistently just like leadership you
know leadership is not a one-day thing
or you do it for two days or two months
leadership is consistent you know an
apple
you know have a longevity in the space
that I'm me and is also consistency as
well not only on the floor but off the
floor as well so glad you mentioned
leadership I was going to get to it but
since we're already on topic I spotted a
picture of you with a copy of leadership
in turbulent times which is a book by
Doris Kearns Goodwin who's also been on
the podcast and I've had a number of
people ask me to ask you about
leadership are there any particular
leaders you admire or or look to and
study who come to mind
you know what's crazy Tim I never grew
up looking for other leaders and saying
I want to beat them or or using what
they did to incorporate it into me I
believe that it was you know it was put
on me before I even wanted to be a
leader my grandmother passed away when I
was three years old and she was kind of
a staple at home
and my mother had me when she was 16 but
she was still in school so you're not
being the only child being one of the
few men in the house I kind of had to
grow up and be kind of one of the
leaders of the household very young
before I even wanted to before you were
on any cow any child to become a leader
and then once you get into team sports
and you you find some success but you
see how you're succeeding you understand
that it's not just about you you
understand that you know in order for
you to continue to be successful
everyone has to feel important everyone
wants to you know feel like they had
something to do with the success and be
a part of it and I sense that you know
at an early age and it's just continued
until you know my adulthood as well so I
can't even sit here and say that I look
you know for leadership throughout
others not I've admired leaders like you
know Martin Luther King he's one of the
greatest leaders I've ever had an
opportunity to just read about and watch
from afar obviously you know Muhammad
Ali as well you know as one
Barack Obama is another and being my
mother I mean I believe my mother is one
of the greatest leaders and just in the
fact that being a single parent mother
in the inner city without any financial
stability and being able to raise a kid
on her own at age 16 so I had you know
those examples but for me I've always
kind of learned on the fly as well your
mother the more I've done research the
more incredible your mother seems to me
how is how has she impacted the way that
you think about parenting or being a
father
I'm wall from the beginning you know
being a part of a single-parent
household when I you know when I found
when I've decided I want to have a
family you know I was like I'm always
gonna be a part of my kid's life and no
matter what what goes on in my life I
just can't you know having my kids have
some of the same why questions that I
had when I was younger and then it's
about you know the perseverance and the
patience of being a parent is what I
learned from my mom my mom was just so
persevering and for me she never had me
in a situation where I felt like I
wasn't special like I wasn't wanted to
do the best kids in the world and and
then from you know the like I said that
leadership standpoint she was just
always a rock no matter what was going
on she was always a rock and very
patient with the process and I and I've
taken that not only to being a father
but you know in life in general always
preach this process thing because I I
just fell in love with it I fell in love
with the process throughout my whole
life
and throughout my basketball career to a
point where I don't I don't like to look
at the ending you know because I like to
just live in the moment and it's the I
think the consistency which is is is
such a focus for a lot of at least my
listeners when they're looking at your
career it's it's been astonishing to
watch over time and many people want to
know about the habits or the reminders
things along these lines and one of the
things I came across
I don't know if it's true you could tell
me but did you it's at one point have
Theodore Roosevelt's man in the arena
quote in your locker still do you still
do why why is riding a riot on my shoes
every game - all right why is that
important to you it just hit home for me
at a point in time where I was listening
to people that I shouldn't be listening
to meaning you know there are always
people out there they're gonna judge you
and critique you and say that you should
do this or you shouldn't do that and and
at that point in time you know I wasn't
mature enough to just believe in with
the decisions that I've made and I'm a
true believer in the more and more that
you listen to things like that then it
equipment to your mind you start to
believe it and once I started to study
some of the great leaders that we've had
in our in our in our time I ran across
that that quote from Theodore Roosevelt
a man in an arena in it basically for
our listeners that don't know about it's
basically saying that it it truly
doesn't matter what anyone says because
they they've never stepped inside the
arena they've never had the blood and
the sweat and the tears or paid a dues
inside the arena so they can't really
understand or critique you about what
your was going on in your life and that
and that hit home for me and that stuck
with me for you know to this day yeah
it's such a tremendous tremendous quote
Mike I'd love to come back to something
you mentioned earlier which was recovery
never ending and if I'd like to talk
about the I suppose third of our lives
or so that we spend asleep is there is
there how do you think about sleep and
is there anything you do to optimize
sleep or to help LeBron and others to
optimize their sleep oh by the way Timmy
gets on me every single day my sleep
here last night how much sleep how much
sleep you get to nine hours all the time
yeah by the way that that muffling you
hear in the background is LeBron
actually removing
ice bags oh yes I like like we just said
recovery never stops right well we're
sitting here doing this podcast in Los
Angeles and LeBron is continuing to ice
his knees and the rest of his body right
now in the middle of this podcast and so
Mike I'd love to hear your thoughts on
sleep this is something that a lot of
people struggle with and it would seem
to be a very important potential asset
for someone who is taxing his body as
much as LeBron is absolutely yeah I mean
um you know we've always learned and
what I was told abroad about the body
does recover and it heals itself while
while we're asleep while we reach our
REM sleep in our deep sleep so any
athlete any and you know I have to be
professional athlete you know whatever
athlete at whatever level you can be a
businessman and doctor lawyer cetera you
know you need your sleep guys and you
you must sleep in order to recover from
from whatever it is either playing an
NBA game or you know a big night or a
big day in the courtroom you know in the
hospital rooms whatever you know
sleeping is when the body heals itself
so it's it's it's it's very very
important are there any particular
techniques or tools or recommendations
that that you found to be helpful with
athletes or that you've you've tested
and found effective yeah you know with
without you know you've given everybody
all of our secrets right um you know
number one is be very accountable you
know in in that room you know just
create an environment you know for us
it's always you know for LeBron it's
always in this hotel room making sure
the temperature set at a particularly
you know probably 68 to 70 degrees is
probably optimal making sure the room is
completely dark you know you have no
distractions trying to turn off you know
your your electronics your all your
electronics in these artists televisions
you know your phones etc just turn
everything off probably half hour to 45
minutes before you actually you know
want to go to sleep and just really
committing yourself to that you know
and we all love the scroll on the
internet and in our social media
accounts at night you know to catch up
on everything but you know you owe it to
yourself and you want to your recovery
just to just to commit to just creating
an environment again the room at are
applicable temperature a dark dark room
you know a comfortable bed etc and you
know it's some people that even use
sleep apps you know I you know like soft
music or you know I love it I love a
nicely back oh yeah what do you what
what do you use LeBron currently or what
dude is the app called calm actually did
I yeah yeah and and and I'm the I'm the
guy who picks rain on leaves I love it
that's what go that's what goes on am I
follow throughout the night random radar
leaves the secret to success I love it
and look LeBron what has become more
important to you from a health or
wellness perspective as you've become
older more seasoned does anything come
to mind us as having become more
important yeah absolutely just we
talking about right now at a topic that
we don't sleep I mean it's nothing more
important than you know optimal REM
sleep and that's with us exactly retama
right now like you know that's the best
way for your body to physically and
emotionally be able to recover and get
back to a hundred percent as possible
now will you wake up and feel 100
percent there's some days you don't some
some days you feel better than others
but the more and more and more time that
you get those eight those even if you
can get nine that's amazing sometimes I
even get 10 hours of sleep and if I
don't get those eight to nine hours at
night then I'll go home I'm I'm gonna
tell you right now it's in when I leave
here I'm gonna go home and take me a nap
for probably two and a half hours to I
just think that's just the best way to
recover I mean is it I could do all the
training I can do all the the ice bags
and the the Norma texts and every
we do that we have as far as our
recovery package while I'm up but when
when you're getting that good sleep and
you just wake up and you feel fresh
there's you don't need alarm clock you
just feel like okay I can I can tackle
this day at the highest level that you
can get to it one thing I've also seemed
to pick up just as a pattern is your
willingness to experiment and I'm sure
that goes for both of you but the the
topic of diet is one I'd love to discuss
because it seems like you've tested many
different diets ranging from low-carb to
probably high carb and everything in
between could you give us an example of
where you are now like let's take just
yesterday could you tell us about some
of the meals that you had or some of the
food that you consume yesterday what
that looks like
well let me let me think about it yeah
yesterday I had a white omelet with the
with smoked salmon and gluten-free
pancakes with just berries that was my
breakfast for lunch I had whole wheat
pasta salmon and vegetables and right
before the game I had a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich and I have time I had
sliced apples with almond butter on top
right after the game Mike gave me a
protein shake to put in my system right
after I downed that right after the game
last night
and then for dinner I had I had chicken
parm with a rocket salad and a beautiful
glass of Cabernet you have no idea how
happy that detail makes me thank you for
this that was my full day of uh yeah
that was it right there you also have a
very good memory and and I've been
meaning to I wasn't sure how to shoehorn
this in but you gave me an opening you
enjoy your wine no do you have any
favorite wines that you can that you can
mention or types of wines
I have so many gem I can't stay here and
say what is my favorite but I am
definitely a board of fan huge board Oh
fan they are some you know cabs that I
love as well but there's some brands
that I love as well I love you know we
get to the higher level as far as you
know like screaming eagle you know Keith
or Ellie you know Rothschild there's
like a whole Latour there's so many
different wines that I actually love so
we really sitting here all day
Maya of my cellar and I got going on at
home that's that's round two
King James sommelier that'll be the next
is there is there anything that and this
this this can go out to either of you
guys but anything that you will not
touch is there but besides the obvious
kind of out of bounds illicit stuff but
are there any foods or drinks anything
in the food realm that you really just
try to avoid a hundred percent yeah I
think right now we'll we try to stay
away from and you know I don't want to
say even try to stay away from we
haven't had in a long time it's
artificial drinks artificial sugars and
fried foods I know we kind of stay away
from the fried foods at least during the
season and and that's to both yes to
both accounts you know I have you know
artificial drinks you know from time to
time in offseason but during a season I
pretty much don't have any fried foods
and I don't have anything that's
artificial we want to keep it as uh you
know as you know just natural sugars and
you know the foods is as much as
possible just try to be clean as
possible throughout the season when I'm
burning it so much and trying to get the
recovery but it's it's it's all about
less as more as far as nutrition goes
you know we just keep it simple so we
try to stay organic the entire year
again like like a run just mention no
artificial
ingredients you know and just the
hydration I think one thing that we
talked about yesterday's game day was
that every every time I saw bran I had a
bottle of water in his face making sure
he was drinking mm-hmm that's one thing
and Mike I want to come back to one
thing that LeBron mentioned I would I'd
be very curious to know if you have
postgame if you have a preferred type of
protein doesn't have to be a brand
although it could be but are you
providing whey protein isolate are you
providing a mixture of different
proteins what what are you giving him in
that protein that protein shake right
after a game I travel I try to go light
with it I don't give him a heavy whey
protein because his body is in a
recovery phrase right and he needs to
absorb everything that he can everything
clean like we just mentioned so I try to
give him a plant-based protein powder
you know with like an almond milk or
something like that some fruits and just
just clean calories him just just giving
clean calories because the first 30
minutes after activity you know after a
game after a practice practice etc you
know the body's like a sponge and it's
gonna absorb you know whatever you give
it so I just try to stay clean stay away
from my animal products for the first
hour you know after after a high calorie
composition thank you but LeBron I would
love to chat about self talk for a
minute because I've I've watched you
playing
I've watched video footage of you
throughout your life and it's it's
obvious to me at least it seems that
that there's quite a bit going on behind
behind the scenes meaning in your own
head and that you're very good at
centering yourself what do you say to
yourself or is there anything in
particular that you say to yourself as
you're getting prepared for a big game
or right before a big game
or after a hard loss for instance yeah I
think for me personally before a big
game um I'm pretty consistent with my
routine and
you're not trying to do the same thing
every single day on a game day because
that's just how I lock in and so right
before I write on the floor I'm just
basically thinking about the game plan
that the culture staff has given us what
do I need to do personally not only for
me to be successful for my teammates to
ultimately be successful in homily these
guys throughout good times and bad times
or the course of a game because that's
what happens it's inevitable that that's
going to happen and then to your notion
of after a bad loss kind of read
thinking about and replaying the game to
my head
what happened throughout the course of
the game that made this loss become a
bad loss what did i do what did I not do
what did we not do you know because I
want to be better I don't want to dwell
on that loss but I do want to know what
there were things that I could have done
or we could have done to prevent it if
it happens next time because I always
preach you know the best teacher in life
is experienced and and it's okay for you
to experience defeat but when you you're
at a position where you may have to
cross that threshold again do you
approach it the same way or do you learn
from that and that's what I try to do I
try to put myself in a mental state of
how do I learn from that defeat how do I
learn from that loss mm-hmm and and
you're the leader of guys on a team who
are all multimillionaires some of the
best athletes in the world with all
sorts of different personalities how do
you how do you think about supporting
them when things go sideways or when
people get frustrated how do you that
have you learned to be most helpful and
effective in those circumstances I think
if one number one thing is patience
and I think when I talk about patience
it comes back to being a father you know
I have three kids and I want the best
out of my kids just like any parent in
the world but what I've learned is that
to get the best out of my three kids
I can't approach them all the same way
because they all have different
personalities they all are different and
had to find out how to I tap into each
one of my kids to get the same result
but teach them differently and that's
the same with being the leader of a
basketball team the leader of a
franchise you may not you can't you
can't express or talk to everyone the
same way and expect to get the same
result or get the most out of them
because every personality is different
so one thing I may say that one player
may trigger a certain different response
than another player and that's what the
patience comes in 10 because you have to
learn that you can't go in and say this
is how I'm a lead yes I'm a leader but
there's ways to lead because you have to
learn those things that you can you know
how do you approach this manner if this
happens you know how you can speak to
him you know how you can speak to to
this player to that player to get what
you want to get out of them so it comes
back to that that patience of learning
their mindsets learning how can you get
the most out of them what triggers them
to be best to be their best what
triggers them to not be their best so
you learn that over time and in the case
of your own pregame routine I am
fascinated by the repetition of routines
that work as it as it stands right now
what what do you have in your pregame
playlist what is what is what is the
music that that you listen to it's gonna
be hip-hop for sure any state any
specifics know if there's you know as
crazy Tim is know specifics it's like
when I when I once I start my routine
but basically once I get to the arena
that's when I start my routine as far as
music it's just it's a field for an
artist that particular time that I know
it's gonna get me going and it could be
an artist from from New York it could be
an artist from California it could be an
artist from Florida from Texas from the
Midwest it all depends on what what
artist pops into my head that I know
there's gonna get me going get my juices
flowing and get get my routine going so
I don't have like it's just a set game
day routine I'm all over the place and
that's
that comes also from being a historian
of music as well
mm-hmm what is what is your tattoo I've
wanted to ask this there's no real
obvious segue for this but I've wanted
to know this seems to be an important
theme in your life that the tattoo that
you have loyalty on your side can you
explain what that means to you yeah you
know my other side it says families yeah
you know it's basically it's
self-explanatory you know when I talk
about my family you know my family is
everything to me and it's a personal
mantra of mine to always be loyal to my
family you know not you know you're
gonna have ups and downs with your
family that happens there's gonna be
times where you you know you don't like
what your family do or your family don't
likes what you do but at the end of the
day we're all loyal to to one another
and you know and that's okay that
happens that's what a family is a family
you know it's not a bed of roses it
comes with thorns and you have to
understand that but at the end of the
day we will never let someone else
infiltrate those thorns and you know so
when I got that tattooed on my on my
ribs
that's basically what it came down to
family loyalty and us always sticking
together no matter the trials and
tribulation is the turbulence the good
the bad ugly the sunshine and the
thunderstorms so that's what it came
down to and and Mike if I could
use that to lead into a question for you
how do you support your athletes when
they're going through a difficult time
whether that is an injury an unexpected
setback psychologically having trouble
contending with something that has that
has happened whether it's on the court
or off the court are there any
particular approaches that you've found
to be helpful a whether it's in the last
few years or just over the course of
your career yeah I think I think the the
number one thing for me has always been
remained consistent remain consistent
through the ups and downs and everything
in between as LeBron said
you know because they're there if there
is a setback if there is you know
something something going on you know I
always have to remain consistent with
with my job and with what I do now I can
always add or augment you know something
that that I feel might be beneficial you
know if it's something as small as uh I
don't know a certain gift of kindness
you know just asking about the family
you know are things okay outside of
basketball are things okay outside of
you know the athletic realm the effete
ik world and just try to just try to be
there for him I'm just trying through
again it's all great when you know we're
scoring forty five points a night and
doing all these all these wonderful
things but is the athlete okay is
thatthe Lee doing well
mentally and spiritually and so I I try
I try to address it you know in a
multi-faceted fashion mm-hmm and for for
you Mike in the offseason
how do your priorities change if at all
for say LeBron in terms of training and
anything else that comes to mind I think
in the offseason we have to be smart you
know LeBron gives everything he has for
these nine months you know and so my job
was to be is to be smart about what
we're doing as far as a volume of
training that we're doing you know and
how much I see him although we do you
know tend to see each other pretty much
every other day in the summer time but
it's it's what we're doing and it's you
know managing engage in his body
throughout the summer time yeah he's a
lot more calm than I am Tim in the
summit consistently tells me hey listen
man you need to take a little bit more
time off we just went for nine and a
half three months and I know do you
LeBron have any any particular favorite
exercises or forms of physical
recreation in the offseason I've read
about yoga Pilates verse a climber
has come up a lot are there other are
there any any particular ingredients
that let you like to regularly inject
into your offseason yeah besides the
Versa climber I actually really like
running on the football field mm-hmm for
two reasons
your outside which is always a cool way
to to exercise and then it kind of takes
me back to my high school days of
playing the game of football yeah you
know and and I just have a huge deep
love of the game of football so you know
get being able to get that conditioning
and get that cardio being outside but
also being back on a football field it
just does something for me personally
and what what might one of those
workouts look like are you doing 400
meter repeats are you doing long steady
and slow what type it's more like
hundred yard Sprint's mm-hmm you know
from end zone to end zone and we we
don't never have like a set number of
how many we want to do but we do enough
to we want to get our heart rate going
you know while we out there and how do
you how do you decide when to stop
because that would seem to be really
critical for like you say like you hear
Mike just say he pulls the rings he says
okay now that's enough Mike a name
that's come up a lot in doing research
for this conversation is Tim Grover and
could you explain who that is and what
you've what you've learned from him well
me growing up you know I'll take it back
a little bit you know I was a big Jordan
fan you know Chicago Bulls and so I was
in my own research know back when you
know all you had was you know you know
press instead of in the internet and so
I was doing just asking around you know
reading you know reading up on Jordan
and the stuff that he was doing for his
body so his name came up a lot of times
and so I finally I gathered the stones
to to get to reach out to Tim you know
just some somehow I tracked down his
number and I told what I wanted to do I
want to learn from him
and he says okay well why don't you come
up to Chicago and you know kind of
intern or intern for us for for a couple
of weeks and MJ will be with us he'll be
getting ready to work with the
Washington Wizards you know he just
signed his deal with the Wizards and so
I'm gonna love doing that so you're more
than welcome to come up and you know
thank God thank God that I caught Tim in
a great mood that day
and so you know so he invited me up to
Chicago and I spent a few weeks with him
with him and with along with MJ and I
learned a lot I learned a lot in those
two weeks I learned you know how to how
to work with an elite athlete of Michael
stature so it was it was invaluable I
learned what to do what not to do what
you know stuff I should stay away from
yourself I should really augment so it
was a great education great educational
experience for me in terms of things to
stay away from was there anything that
sticks out in your mind as a key
learning or takeaway in that department
or it could be one of the other
categories but is there any anything
specific that that that comes to mind
anything specific as far as natholi
training working with with an athlete of
that caliber is to remain consistent to
remain consistent you know it there's no
particular exercise there's no
particular stretch it's all about your
own mindset and your own confidence
working with someone like Mike and out
obviously working with someone like like
they're like LeBron so it's all about
how to approach it mentally and how to
be consistent for that athlete again
just just be that rock consistency he
says this this is a good opportunity all
right go ahead and available and
available
you know 24/7 I may wake up at like 3
o'clock in the morning want to get a
workout in yeah on the on-demand which
which I think it is a good window to
start chatting about a new collaboration
that you're both involved with LeBron
you've you've become a very active
businessman and investor over the course
of your career and there are many things
we could discuss
lated to that but one that I think is
very relevant to our conversation right
now is is ladder and there are a lot of
people out there who are constantly
asking themselves and every time they
get to New Year's make resolutions
related to loving and not dreading
fitness and wellness and if trying to
try to find a way to attack it that
leads them to passion and not feeling
burdened with responsibility could could
you guys and either one of you can can
grab this explain what ladder is and and
what is what is the purpose behind it um
I think with the but with the whole idea
behind ladder and you know starting this
company m''d way back probably around
2014 we were kind of in a crossroads of
okay what else could we add to our to
our to our to our routine as far as
nutrition goes you know I felt like we
were just beginning to scratch the
surface as to what was available out
there but unfortunately we found that
you know some of the stuff that that
that's out there you know they are these
big companies have all these proprietary
blends and we weren't sure you know okay
what what exactly is in these
proprietary blends and so you know we
will start we will start with the
company but we start with something off
the shelf that was NSF certified but you
know we just didn't didn't want to take
the chance of you know to continue to
use these products and so we don't we
got together with LJ and said you know
let's really do some more research as to
what what is out there that that is not
available for us in and why not and so
we started to do some more research
after 2014 when unfortunately he
experienced you know that the the the
much publicized and critiqued cramping
game 2014 during the finals you know
that's when LeBron and I really got
together and said okay what are we
missing here you know what why we
cramped in here we're doing everything
we can for hydration
now let's let's let's dive deeper into
this because it's obviously affecting
our performance and our productivity you
know maybe to some degree cost us the
championship so we started doing like I
said more and more research as to what's
out there and just we finally came up
with with the right ingredients and you
know what like we mentioned earlier we
kept it simple town we kept it really
really simple and very transparent to
the public as to what what we were
what's what's in these products right
and it's it's you mentioned a few things
that I want to underscore for folks also
you know the NSF certified for sport
just you know effectively considered the
gold standard for testing and approved
by not only the major sports teams but
the IOC and so on so for for for
competitors extremely important to know
exactly what you're putting into your
bodies for any any number of of reasons
but and and for for people who are
looking for the supplementation or tools
to augment their physical activity
you've you've also assembled a very
strong team of founders it says wearing
if you could chat a little bit about the
the people involved and why that
particular team has been assembled for
this well I can I could talk about that
Tim you know obviously two of our
founders are honest Orson Egger and
Cindy Crawford and and not to speak up
on Arnold for one we we've been in
business for quite a while now together
to a mutual friend of ours and obviously
his history of what he's done in history
as far as nutrition and and and in
training and things that goes without
even know that without even talking
about we know how unbelievable he's been
in his career so that that makeup and
that match fit perfectly and also the
same with Cindy Crawford as well you
know she's you know been doing the
Wellness and the health and in the
training and everything she's been doing
throughout her whole life and it made
sense for her to be a part of the team
as well and we also
have you know Lindsey Vonn as well you
know one of the greatest you know
athletes of her John room in her craft
as well so we wanted to be able to
assemble not only people that has
actually live this life but also people
that people can relate to as well so it
all made sense for all of us mm-hmm and
looking at the the materials that that I
reviewed the the the message in effect
of life is a work out and recognizing
that the physical part of your life is
really part of everything right I mean
it is that it is the vehicle for
everything else and your mind is part of
your body so if you want to care for
that you also have to care for the
overall package that is your physical
totality I is LeBron you must have
thousands of opportunities come to you
and get pitch to you I would imagine on
not just a annual basis but a monthly or
weekly basis I mean you could drown in
the number of pitches you would receive
why is this important to you Blackie
goes back to what Mike was speaking upon
you know we had that that moment during
the finals we were kind of mind boggling
because we we know how much you know we
know how much we take care of the body
we know how much we you know put into
the body what we put into our body we
know how much liquids and throughout
throughout the whole day and for that to
happen at a very important moment in my
career we were searching for answers and
for us to get to this point now where we
found the answers I told Mike listen you
go out and do the research
I trust you outbid with you for over a
decade plus now only thing I ask is that
we make sure that everything is clean
because that's you know that's what's
most important in anything you know I
you know I've trained my body we've
trained our body throughout this whole
process and you know my body more than I
know it so that's how it all got started
and I think you know everything that
I've ever done tim has always been
authentic to myself I mean you know
authentic to what
do on a day-to-day basis if it's from
you know a few years ago having a
bike-a-thon in my hometown is it all
steamed from me
training riding mountain bikes in the
summertime for getting back into shape
you know so that's what how that came
about if it's anything I've done in my
career has always been authentic to who
I am you look at like you said some of
the things that I'm doing now as far as
the production of TV shows and things of
that nature is stems from me loving TV
and loving the fact that being to engage
people's mind and emotions and things
that nature is authentic to myself and
that's what that's what ladder is all
about as well mm-hmm and it is ladder
also going to have an editorial resource
component because of the the the URL we
are ladder calm as I understand it is is
also going to have a lot of answers to
questions with scientifically supported
responses to topics ranging from you
know fitness nutrition to various types
of health problems how do you envision
you know Mike maybe if you want to chat
yeah on that side of things how do you
how do you envision that serving people
and what would people go there to find
yeah I mean it's a you know we want to
provide a one-stop shop for for athletes
and for you know for everyone else you
know who's interested in in maybe you
know getting some sort of gain from from
not only a product but but from just a
lifestyle stance here you know we can
all improve could all improve and in
whatever field that we're in whether we
take it by leaps and bounds over tell
you by inches we get all could all
improve and part of it is creating that
environment you know but by environment
I mean that website you know the social
media stuff where athletes can go in and
and tap into our resources and our
resources you know it can be a panel of
experts in their field you know and not
only athletic performance but you know
social behavior psychological behaviors
mental stuff it's all
vital it's not vital and it's more about
the athletic realm it's about living
your best life I guess you know and
improving this is mice's something that
that fits a very particular sort of Venn
diagram for me which is something that
was born out of the two of you
scratching your own itch right you
mentioned the the cramping in 2014 and I
I'm always most interested when a
service or product is born out of an
unaddressed need an unmet need from one
of the founders themselves and it seems
like you'll be making tools available to
people that would otherwise well perhaps
be be limited to some of these high
level athletes you mentioned and that's
exciting
I would I would also be remiss if I
didn't ask you LeBron and will I know we
we have just a few minutes left here but
how many more years would you like to
play I would love to see the floor with
my son mm-hmm my son is in eighth grade
now if he continues on the path that
he's on right now he could possibly be
in the NBA in five six years so amazing
we that would be that would be an
unbelievable moment for her now and
myself but for my family for my for
everybody
so we see I was taking care of the body
is number one and we will you know do
that but more importantly taking care of
the mind if your mind's not fresh then
your body a fall at the waistline so do
to do the grace of the man above and to
everything that myself and Mike and you
know cannot support team do that would
be that would be pretty dang on cool if
I'm able to be on the NBA floor with my
uh my oldest son that would be amazing
well I look forward to watching that and
you guys have been very generous with
your time I appreciate you making it
happen and I'm very excited to see what
both of you do and what ladder does
people can find ladder at we are ladder
comm of course
LeBron you're everywhere at King James
on Twitter and Instagram LeBron on
Facebook Mike I'm not sure smoke signals
a carrier pigeon how should people how
should people find you if there is a way
to find you or should they just just
watch your good deeds through the
through the athletes that you work with
you know what I think our body of work
together you know we will abound in the
court I think that's that's that that's
proof proof in itself if you do want to
follow on Instagram it's it's my
fanciest one and that's instead thing I
have the same Twitter handle as well
perfect
I'm pretty sure it's it's all good it's
all good and it's an exciting journey
for me absolutely beautiful
right and I will link to everything
we've discussed people listening in the
show notes as per usual Tim top block
forward slash podcast and LeBron we
didn't have time today to get into the
Family Foundation but you're doing
incredible work and I want to just thank
you among many other thanks for doing so
much for the kids of Akron I think it's
it's really tremendous I've looked very
closely at it myself for the inspiration
for things I hope to do so I appreciate
you putting that much time and effort
and care back into the community that
you came from appreciate it Sam thank
you very much all right well guys I will
let you get running
you have you have icing to do you have
who knows who knows what else to get
done in the meantime and I wish you both
the best of luck and look forward to
seeing what you guys do thank you thanks
very much bye-bye
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using probably
about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies Hart do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes at
it every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip-hop rock and roll or say
low-impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite liked Matt Wilber
and I tend to do on-demand and listen to
a lot of and watch many of the same
classes over and over but I'm kind of
promiscuous and also enjoy classes from
a lot of the other instructors they have
peloton an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in New York City for the
whole range of styles and personalities
so you can find what you're in the mood
for you also get real-time metrics that
you can use to track your performance
over time and that will help I would say
catalyze you to beat your personal best
now that all sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way and sin devised me but they
really 100% hit the nail on the head I
was very very impressed with how
motivating it was and it worked
tremendously to keep me pushing which
quite honestly takes a fair amount I can
get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me
so check it out discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings the studio experience right to
your home peloton is offering listeners
to this podcast a limited time offer
go to one peloton comm that's full and a
peloton PE L OTO and.com and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your polish
on bike purchase so get a great workout
at home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started this episode is brought
to you by 99designs 99designs
is the global creative platform that
makes it easy for designers and clients
to work together from logos to apps
packaging to books 99designs is the
go-to design resource for any budget
I've used 99designs
for many many years now I've used them
for book covers for instance mock-ups
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become a number one New Times bestseller
illustrations for my multi-volume the
Tao of Seneca and other graphic design
projects and I've
really impressed by the quality of their
designers and the designs that I've been
using most recently I use 99 designs to
update the illustrations and layouts of
my five morning rituals eBook this
covers my most consistent morning
routines and rituals and I offer that as
an incentive for people to sign up for
my newsletter so this is a PDF bonus
that acts as a carrot to increase the
number of email subscribers the
illustrations inside are gorgeous and I
loved working with the designer who we
selected for the project so you can
check it out take a look at that at 99
designs comp or slash Tim that's the
number 99 designs com forward slash Tim
but you can see exactly what I'm talking
about with a real world example of what
has come out of work with them
nunya and designs designer search tool
connects you directly with one designer
based on the design category or an
industry specialization styles the level
availability and more so you can really
check all the boxes that you need and
see who matches up or you can start a
contest and that means you invite the
entire community to take a shot at your
project then you pick your favorite
right now you guys my listeners that is
can receive a free $99 upgrade on your
first design contest so check it out to
see what it looks like to get your first
free upgrade please visit 99designs
dot-com for Tim and click on the link in
the landing page so again check it out
99 designs dot-com forward slash temp
you
you